estamos en el problema número 7 el
problema número 7 que dice a cuadrada -
b cuadrada esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 7 y tanto a como b son enteros y
positivos cuánto valen el valor de amd
ok
guau este problema me va a gustar
bastante se ve que está padrísimo fíjate
bien y seguro que hay varias formas de
resolver esto pero creo que una forma
original de pensar esto que tengo aquí
es que te parece si factor izamos esta
expresión de que arriba esto es una
diferencia de cuadrados por lo tanto es
exactamente lo mismo que a más be ok ya
esto x a menos b x
-háblenos b y esto es igual a 7 ahora
tanto a como b son enteros positivos por
lo tanto cuando él me tomó a más b pues
esto de aquí también va a ser un entero
positivo estás de acuerdo ahora
si estoy aquí es positivo entonces esto
de acá esta expresión que tengo aquí
también tiene que ser positivo porque no
hay de otra un positivo por un positivo
siempre me da un número positivo y bueno
eso me va ayudar a resolver este
problema porque fíjate en este número de
aquí en el siete el siete es un número
cuyos únicos factores es 7 y 1 el 7 lo
podemos ver como 7 por 1 y nada más por
lo tanto uno de estos dos tiene que ser
7 y el otro tiene que ser 1 porque son
enteros positivos estos dos números de
aquí ahora suena muy lógico que estos
dos del principio
además me den 7 y que a - bm de 1 a más
va a ser un número mucho más positivo
mucho más grande que me los vemos si me
tomo la diferencia entre ellos
por lo tanto 7 tiene que ser lo mismo
que a más b mientras que por otro lado
uno tiene que ser lo mismo que a menos
ven ok y esto es de que me va a servir
bueno pues yo quiero dos números cuyas
de 7 y cuya diferencia me de uno y si
hacemos un poco de memoria me vas a
decir que de una manera muy fácil a debe
de ser 4 y b debe de ser 3 3 4 7 y 4
menos 3 es 1 y ya tendríamos la
respuesta correcta porque lo que me
preguntaban era cuál era el valor de up
a vale 4 ahora también hay otra forma de
hacerlo de aquí podríamos obtener un par
de ecuaciones a más b es igual a 7 y la
otra me quedaría que a menos b es igual
a 1 y aquí tengo un sistema de
ecuaciones con dos incógnitas lo cual
también es muy fácil de resolver si no
puedes obtener que vale 4 y b vale 3
lote saliendo un principio puedes
resolver este sistema de ecuaciones y
que me va a quedar amasar verdad no sé
si son vuestras dos ecuaciones más ve -
ve estos dos se van y siete más uno
de aquí puedo obtener que es igual a 4 y
bueno de una manera muy sencilla
despejando de esta ecuación o de esta
ecuación a b voy a obtener que me vale 3
que es justo lo que yo quería este
problema me gustó bastante que por
cierto tiene como solución el inciso b
ya está y hasta aquí la solución del
problema número 7 que se me hizo un
problema bastante original pero bueno es
hora de resolver el siguiente problema
que tiene una recta numérica así que
vamos a hacer la recta numérica de una
vez tengo aquí mi recta numérica algo
más o menos así tengo que por aquí va
hacia los negativos por aquí base los
positivos justo aquí en medio tengo al
cero por acá tengo al 1 ok por acá tengo
al menos uno y me dan un montón de
puntos así que vamos a ponernos qué
puntos tengo por aquí esparcidos de esta
recta numérica me dicen que por aquí
está t
ok por aquí está
por aquí está bien y por aquí está w
por aquí está x por aquí está bien y
para finalizar por acá está z lo que me
preguntan es más o menos aproximadamente
a cuánto equivale el valor absoluto de
un menos b yo lo que quiero saber es a
cuánto equivale el valor absoluto de uno
menos b en relación con estos puntos y
bueno este es un típico problema de
aproximación lo que me piden no es de
una manera exacta cuánto vale un menos b
porque de hecho no los tengo aquí
representados de una manera contundente
y exacta lo que me piden es una
aproximación de cuánto equivale un menos
ven así que como lo que queremos es
aproximar un poco todo este resultado
y que me dé uno de los puntos que
tenemos aquí que te parece si ponemos
valores voy a decir que uno
o es un número que está muy cercano a
menos 1 qué te parece si me lo tomo como
menos punto 92.8 lo voy a tomar como
menos punto 85 este número está entre
menos 2.8 y menos punto 9 así que me
agrada para uno y para ver bueno pues
esta antes de la mitad entre menos uno y
cero está cercano a que te parece si lo
ponemos como menos puntos 6 ok lo voy a
tomar con menos puntos 6 para tomar un
aproximado y ver qué es lo que pasa
entonces este es el valor de 1 este es
el valor de b y vamos a ver qué
obtenemos del valor absoluto de uno
menos b
esto sería igual al valor absoluto de
menos punto 85 menos menos punto seis
cuidado con los signos aquí es menos
menos este menos y aquí tengo menos
punto 6
hay que conservar los siglos y esto en
valor absoluto esto es importantísimo
tener cuidado con los signos
cuánto es esto bueno pues vamos a ver
esto es lo mismo que el valor absoluto
de 2.85 más o menos por menos es más más
punto 6.6 y esto es igual al valor
absoluto de 2.25 que por cierto cuando
yo me tomo el valor absoluto de un
número negativo me lo manda a su
correspondiente el número positivo 0.25
es decir me voy a fijar en uno de estos
puntos que esté a un cuarto entre cero y
uno a un cuarto entre cero y uno pues es
x parece ser que el resultado es x es
este valor de aquí es más o menos me
aproximado de la diferencia entre 12 b
en valor absoluto y vamos a ver en la
recta numérica siguiente cuantas letras
corresponde al valor absoluto de hubo
menos ojo perdón me equivoqué no no no
es v es w o no no no perdón perdón ando
medio medio enamorado el día de hoy
vamos a borrar todo esto
esto todo esto no me sirve y yo lo que
quiero realmente es tomarme el valor
absoluto de un es más lo voy a poner
hasta acá abajo
voy a tachar esto y lo que quiero
realmente es tomarme el valor absoluto
de un menos doble y que bueno realmente
es algo muy parecido vamos a darle un
valor aproximado a w y a mí me late que
w es como pues está justo a la mitad más
o menos entre -1 y 0 es decir que w voy
a decir que es lo mismo que es 0.5
negativo porque estamos en los números
negativos ok entonces me voy a tomar el
valor absoluto de menos punto 85 menos
cuidado con los signos aquí va un
paréntesis menos menos 0.5 0.5 y cuando
es esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo que
el valor absoluto de menos punto
a punto 5 lo cual es el valor absoluto
de menos punto 35 a ver veamos si sí y
esto es lo mismo qué punto 35 positivo
ok que era un número que esté cercano al
valor de punto 35 y de hecho sigue
siendo x tiene otra vez la razón no
vamos tan mal sigue siendo x mi
respuesta x es un punto que está antes
del 0.5 y es mi único punto que está
aquí por lo tanto mi respuesta sigue
siendo x no nos equivocamos tan feo y x
es mi inciso sé pero antes de poner que
es el inciso sem quiero que te des
cuenta de algo cuando yo me estoy
tomando la diferencia entre un menos ven
el valor absoluto esencialmente recuerda
que el valor absoluto no podemos ver
como distancia algo que me estoy fijando
es a la distancia que hay entre un y w
esta distancia es exactamente lo mismo
que el valor absoluto de 1 - w y bueno
pues esta distancia es parecida a esta
distancia que ella
es parecida a esta distancia que hay acá
por lo tanto estas dos instancias son
parecidas y es por eso que mi respuesta
es x ok que por cierto es el inciso c ya
está aquí el problema número 8
bien corremos la pantalla y vamos a
hacer el problema número 9 el problema
número 9 que me dice si el número n al
número n le sumamos 5 al número n le
sumamos 5 y después al resultado de esto
lo multiplicamos por 5 ok a todo esto a
todo esto lo voy a multiplicar por 5 ok
y después el resultado de esto le
restamos 5 o sea a todo esto a todo esto
le voy a restar 5 ok el resultado de
esto le restamos 5 y después al
resultado de todo esto de todo esto se
me tomó ahora esto lo dividimos entre 5
lo dividimos en 35 igual
en términos de en mi resultado final ok
pues aquí hay muchos cincos vamos a ver
si podemos simplificar algo en esta
expresión de aquí aunque te parece que
primero multiplicamos la parte de arriba
tengo 5 n más 25 menos 5 entre 5 lo
único que hice fue distribuir este por
este y este por éste y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que cinco nm más 20
entre 5 pero los padres que aquí tengo
un 5 dividiendo y hay una propiedad de
la división que es lo que me dice es que
me tengo que tomar la división de este
entre éste y la división de este entre
éste o sea que esto es exactamente lo
mismo que 5 nm entre 5 más 20 entre 5
más 20 entre 5 lo cual es lo mismo que
éste y éste se van me queda n a ver
déjame ponerlo con otro color color de
resultado me gusta este
es lo mismo que en más 20 en 35 lo
cuales 4 y esta es mi respuesta en 4 que
por cierto es el inciso d es el inciso
de lo mismo que teníamos que hacer en
este problema era simplificar esta
expresión que tengo aquí se ve mucho más
elegante y más padre en 4 que todos
estos cincos que tenemos acá ok
ese fue el problema número 9 y bueno
déjenme hacer el espacio el problema
número 10 o no no no de hecho no es un
problema de espacio el problema es del
tiempo ya se me acabó el tiempo así que
mejor vemos el siguiente problema el
problema número 10 en el siguiente vídeo
nos vemos pronto